[Music]  we are in the land of reboots now it  feels like everything is being rebooted  so I have to ask you which of your  iconic characters would you even  consider stepping back into I would love  to do a movie from dr. Evil's  perspective so it would be dr. evil one  Austin Powers for that's how I would  role could make that I think that could  happen I think that could happen we  could start the campaign starts a  campaign please thank you Mike Myers is  ready for Austin Powers for the actor  got candid about reprising his role as a  groovy spy while promoting his new heist  thriller terminal bang if I gave you  three words to describe this film but  how would you describe it beautiful  Margo and stylish  [Music]